Salut vous vous demandez sûrement pourquoi ce titre
"disséquer la dame", avec des lettres, 1 ciseau etc et bien simplement parce que disséquer la dame, c'est l'anagramme de :
"le marquis de Sade". Alors pour bien comprendre, faut connaître le marquis de Sade c'était un homme politique,
romancier et philosophe qui adorait mélanger le sexe avec la barbarie donc la violence, le meurtre, l'inceste...
Ouais c'est de là que vient le mot sadique. Et l'anagramme d'un mot, ou l'anagramme d'une phrase, c'est le fait de reprendre toutes les lettres
d'une phrase pour en former une nouvelle. Si on prend toutes les lettres de : "le marquis de Sade"
alors on obtient "disséquer la dame". On dit une anagramme, c'est un nom féminin et aujourd'hui je vais vous donner les meilleurs
anagrammes que j'ai pu trouver qui sont en plus en rapport avec la phrase d'origine ou le mot d'origine. Comme par exemple "soigneur" qui est l'anagramme
de "guérison" c'est pas... c'est pas un peu ouf ?
moi ça me rend dingue. Le but du jeu c'est que vous essayiez vous aussi de trouver, si vous voulez, les anagrammes. Vous pouvez mettre pause,
vous pouvez chercher et j'ai d'ailleurs invité des gens d'une chaîne youtube que j'aime bien, qui s'appelle la Family Coste, à essayer de jouer avec moi
De temps en temps dans les vidéos maintenant vous allez voir apparaître ce pouce. Alors ce pouce il veut dire quoi ? Ce pouce il veut
dire que c'est un coup de pouce. Parfois quand je vais présenter une chaîne, un produit, un
projet, quelque chose que j'aime bien mais qui n'est pas un placement produit, sur lequel je n'ai aucun intérêt
directement, c'est juste un kiff
je mettrai ce truc-là, "coup de pouce ". Pourquoi ? Ben je vais vous le dire, pourquoi. Simplement parce que j'ai remarqué, qu'avec les placements de produits
un peu déguisés etc.
maintenant,
vous les gens, de l'autre côté de l'écran, vous savez jamais quand c'est sincère ou pas. Et bien maintenant, voilà c'est clair, quand il y a
le logo "coup de pouce", ça veut dire que c'est un truc que j'ai kiffé et je veux le mettre en avant. Ce qui est
le cas pour la Family Coste. On commence avec un anagramme très simple "océan"... "Océan" ça fait... Si on mélange un petit peu...
"canoë".
Bon, Ok, "canoë", "océan", on voit un peu le rapport quand même.
"Merveilles", c'est intéressant parce que "merveilles", si on mélange bien - vous pouvez mettre pose si vous voulez chercher - ça fait "mille rêves". J'aime bien.
C'est un petit peu de poésie sur cette chaîne, que diable ! "La crise
économique". Alors moi je trouve que ça a un rapport, après vous trouvez qu'il y a un rapport ou pas, mais c'est assez amusant de voir ça.
C'est un article
et deux mots, qui vont se transformer en un autre article et deux mots. Et pour vous aider, le premier article c'est le. Et la
technique d'Audrey est bonne, parce qu'elle a barré les lettres qui étaient déjà utilisées.
Ensuite elle a préparé les deux mots et donc le premier mot fait bien huit lettres.
- Comique... Comique... Co-mique
- C...o...m...i...q...u...e
Attention, l'un des deux mots vient d'être trouvé.
- C'est ça !
Alors, je sais pas si vous l'aviez vous, mais là Audrey et Seb viennent de trouver que comique était le deuxième mot. Ce qui est bon.
Et dans un anagramme si tu trouves heu, tous les mots sauf un... Là, vous avez de fortes chances de trouver le deuxième
- Ou pas... - Si [rire].
- Pas tant que ça finalement, pas tant que ça [rire]
Scénario ? Oui !
Scénario comique ?
Le scénario comique
- J'avais raison sur le r, i...  - Ouai bon après ça a plus trop à voir quand même avec la crise économique. - C'est subjectif
- C'est subjectif. - Oui... - Pour moi la crise est inventée
- Et que c'est... - Ouai
- et heu, c'est assez juste - Scénario comique, Ok - Mais je suis heureuse, j'en aurai au moins trouvé un
- L'honneur est sauf [rire]
- C'était pas le plus dur, en termes de nombre de lettres, par contre c'était le plus éloigné, en termes de, de, de rapport
- D'accord, ok
"La crise économique", ça donne "le scénario comique". Enfin comique, pas pour tout le monde hein en l'occurrence. Mais "la crise économique"
l'anagramme c'est :
"Le scénario comique". Et puis un que vous connaissez forcément, qui a été adapté d'ailleurs en français pour fonctionner aussi, mais il marchait déjà en anglais
C'est "Tom Elvis Jedusor" qui donne "Je suis Voldemort". Et si t'as pas lu Harry Potter bah forcément, tu passes un peu à côté là...
Alors un grand classique : c'est pas moi qui l'ait trouvé celui ci, mais je le trouve assez fascinant...
C'est : "Le Commandant Cousteau". Pour ceux qui connaîtraient pas le Commandant Cousteau, c'est quelqu'un qui faisait beaucoup de recherches et de reportages sur le milieu
marin à une époque. 'tait un peu la star de l'océan dans les années
80-90 le mec. Y avait pas un mérou qui connaissait pas le Commandant Cousteau.
- Tout commença...
- Exactement ! - Tout commença dans l'... Ah ouai...
- Oui ! ... - Oui... - Bravo la Family Coste ! [Applaudissement]
- Wouuu... !
Si ont fait l'anagramme de : "Le Commandant Cousteau" ça nous donne "Tout
commença dans l'eau ". Je pense qu'on voit dans mes yeux le fait que ça me fascine
J'... j'espère arriver à vous le rendre, ça, à l'écran. "La gravitation universelle".
Donc vous connaissez la loi de la gravité. "La gravitation universelle"
Quelle est son anagramme ?
Si on mélange les lettres ? Il est assez dur à trouver parce qu'il y a beaucoup de mots. Ça commence par "Loi" et ça donne "Loi vitale
régnant sur la vie". "Le triangle des Bermudes". Bien avant les Illuminati il y avait donc le triangle des Bermudes.
Et comme il y a beaucoup de bateaux qui se sont perdus dans le triangle des Bermudes, des avions qui ont eu des problèmes avec les
instruments de bord. Bref, depuis tout temps les marins disaient qu'il se passait des choses très étranges là-bas.
Y avait une rumeur...
est bien l'anagramme de "Le triangle des Bermudes" c'est : "La rumeur des gens de la mer". Ça donne à réfléchir
Y a un anagramme aussi pour la phrase suivante
"L'origine de l'univers". Ça donne un anagramme en quatre mots
"L'origine de l'univers", ça donne un anagramme de quatre mots qui donne : "Un vide noir
grésille". C'est un peu... c'est un peu joli. En fait c'est une vidéo poétique que je vous fais aujourd'hui.
En parlant de poésie vous connaissez aussi forcément cette phrase "Être ou ne pas être,
voilà la question"
Bon, c'est "telle est la question", mais on va mettre "voilà la question" parce que sinon on peut pas faire l'anagramme que j'veux
derrière donc "Être ou ne pas être,
voilà la question".
Et bien si on mélange tout ça, qu'on extrait toutes les lettres, qu'on les réutilise toutes, une fois, pas une fois de moins, pas une
fois de plus, ça nous donne : "Oui et la réponse n'est que vanité orale" donc ça fait "Être ou ne pas être voilà la question"
"Oui et la réponse n'est que vanité
orale". Je trouve que ça colle bien. Dans le même état d'esprit des choses qui collent bien, on a aussi "Les trous noirs"
"Sont irrésolus". Dire que "Les trous noirs"
et "Sont irrésolus", les deux phrases sont une anagramme l'une de l'autre. "Les trous noirs" "Sont irrésolus"
Je crois que je l'ai dis assez de fois. Un autre que j'aime bien pour le côté musical c'est "Robert Schuman"
"Reconnu Brahms". Donc l'anagramme de "Robert Schuman" c'est "Reconnu Brahms". Et c'est vrai que dans l'une de ses lettres, dans l'un de ses écrits
Schuman fait des compliments comme quoi Brahms est un grand artiste
Il a un petit peu donné le tampon, par rapport à la musique que faisait Brahms. Donc "Robert Schuman" "Reconnu Brahms"
c'est un petit peu énorme. Anagramme s'il vous plaît d'"Albert Einstein"
J'ai l'impression d'être dans Questions pour un champion
Un indice en bas de votre écran. Ah, y a un bouton pour mettre un pouce bleu si vous voulez. Ça, ça fait plaisir.
D'ailleurs l'anagramme de "Laisse un pouce bleu"
c'est : "Si aucune poubelles". Bah c'est tout ce que j'ai trouvé. Donc avec toutes les lettres de "Laisse un pouce bleu"
ça fait "Si aucune poubelles".
En clair si y a pas de poubelles dans cette vidéo, tu peux laisser un pouce bleu. Bon je disais, l'anagramme de "Albert Einstein"
Ça donne quoi, si on récupère toutes ces lettres, de son prénom et de son nom de famille. Ça donne "Rien n'est établi"
"Albert Einstein"
"Rien n'est établi". Énorme
"Antoine de
Saint-Exupéry" donc c'est la personne qui a écrit Le Petit Prince. Mais vous savez peut-être aussi qu'il était aviateur et qu'il est vraiment tombé en
panne dans le désert, un petit peu comme dans le livre, le, Le Petit Prince. Et bien l'anagramme d'"Antoine de Saint-Exupéry"
c'est "Doux sire y était en panne". "Doux sire" en référence au petit prince et "y était en panne" pour faire référence à la panne d'avion qu'il
avait eu dans le désert. "Et les particules élémentaires". C'est une très bonne question !
Est ce que vous voulez chercher peut-être un petit peu ? "Et les particules élémentaires". Bon je vous laisse chercher ça
Il est extrêmement compliqué. Ça fait "Tissèrent l'espace et la lumière". Ce qui peut nous donner une phrase complète : "Et les particules élémentaires"
"Tissèrent l'espace et la lumière". Ça a du sens, hein, vous avez vu ! Je vous fais une référence plus historique : "Vercingétorix
roi des gaules". Donc vous vous souvenez, Vercingétorix a déposé ses armes devant César en, en signe de reddition.
Ça a été sa manière de rester fier face à l'ennemi, et face à la défaite. Et bien "Vercingétorix roi des gaules"
l'anagramme de cet ensemble là, donne : "Digne vers toi glorieux César".
"Vercingétorix roi des gaules" "Digne vers toi glorieux César". Y a vraiment un sens caché derrière ses phrases
Alors forcément, c'est du hasard mais c'est assez passionnant. Je vous mets au défi de trouver un anagramme
simple, alors ça peut être juste sur un mot ou sur une phrase complète et de le mettre dans les commentaires de la vidéo.
Vous pouvez aller voir sur internet, mais c'est encore mieux si vous en vous trouvez un vous même. Et comme ça on va se faire,
avec les commentaires, toute une liste non exhaustive
des anagrammes possibles et inimaginaux.
- Dans tous les domaines possibles, et inimaginaux...
Je suis vraiment ravi d'avoir pu vous présenter en même temps la Family Coste, que moi je suis depuis longtemps. Je suis abonné, heu,
à leur chaîne depuis un bon moment. J'vous mets évidemment un lien vers leur chaîne dans la description.
N'hésitez pas à aller checker. Ils se sont fait un petit défi de ouf, de faire le tour du monde en famille, en
quittant tout, enfin je vous laisse voir ça. Je vous invite bien sûr, à vous abonner à cette chaîne. Ça fait du plaisir, c'est
très bien. Si vous avez kiffé la vidéo,
partagez-la. Vraiment, partagez-la, c'est grâce à vous en fait que la chaîne elle grandit aussi. Je compte sur vos pouces par centaines de
milliers. Je ne sais pas pourquoi je prends cet accent et c'est une vidéo
toutes les semaines. J'allais dire tous les jours, en fait deux fois par semaine les mardis et vendredis à 15 heures et un
live le dernier mercredi de chaque mois à 20h20. Je vous dis à très bientôt et heu... ciao. Si ça se trouve y a un anagramme
caché en appuyant sur le cercle heu
juste là au milieu de l'écran. C'est possible. Dans le doute, il faudrait essayer, ça marche même d'un téléphone portable
et si vraiment y a pas d'anagramme, ça va t'abonner et ce serait cool
vraiment cool.